you are watching ColdFusion TV
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
for the first time in history we're
seeing the successful development and
demonstration of general purpose AI its
name is alphago and it was made by
google's deepmind division the alphago
AI algorithm beat a human at the world's
hardest game this is a historic moment
in computer science and artificial
intelligence so what exactly is google
deepmind where did it come from and what
can the company's artificial
intelligence actually do in this video
we'll find out
a computer program beat a human brain of
the ancient Chinese war game of go the
final school for one at triumph or
artificial intelligence equipped with
human intuition victory of a program
over a human in the ancient board game
go has sparked intrigue and in some
cases concern it shows that a machine
has approximated human intuition and
outsmarted the best human brain in the
game it's something that scientists
hadn't expected to happen for at least
another decade and it's a giant leap for
artificial intelligence showing that
machines can learn on their own I think
maybe the game ended because it looks
like we still captain no I think you
resign well I think you're right
this was the moment a computer called
alphago beat a master of the ancient
Chinese game go it's not the first time
a Grand Master's been humbled by a
machine but what makes alphago different
is that it's the first demonstration
that machines can truly learn and think
in a human way alphago's victory shocked
experts in the artificial intelligence
community many thought such an event was
at least a decade away so firstly a few
questions why is this important and
what's all the fuss
alphago shows that machines can really
learn how so well instead of using brute
force to calculate all the moves that
could make like previous a is alphago
used reinforcement learning and neural
networks to mimic the learning process
of a human brain keep in mind that the
ancient Chinese game go has many more
possible moves than chess as there are
atoms in the entire universe so there's
no way of just calculating every
possible move on the board that's
practically impossible for this reason
go is the holy grail of AI and learning
to do such a task from scratch is a huge
feat further to this deepmind's creators
say that the algorithm can learn many
more things without alteration or
guidance in other words the AI is
general-purpose we always used to talk
about what if we could eventually crack
go and have a program that could be the
world champion then we must have
invented some generic general-purpose
algorithm so maybe we're on the cusp of
all of them if you ask a great go player
why they play the particular move
sometimes they'll just tell you it felt
right so you can the one way to think of
it is that go is a much more intuitive
game whereas chess is a much more logic
based game so what is deep mind google
deepmind is a british artificial
intelligence company that was founded in
September of 2010 as deepmind
technologies was renamed when it was
acquired by Google in 2014 for 500
million dollars interestingly enough
this was just after Facebook had just
finished negotiations with them in 25
and another fun fact Elon Musk is
actually an investor in the company just
to keep an eye on them of course deep
mine received the company of the Year
award by the Cambridge computer
laboratory in 2014
so where did deep mind come from deep
mind was first to start up co-founded by
demis hassabis in 2010 Dennis was a
child genius of sorts and went from
being a chess prodigy and reaching
master level at age 13 on to becoming
the lead programmer of Lionhead Studios
for groundbreaking games such as black
and white after this he went on to start
his own gaming studio before leaving to
complete some extra studies at the
University College of London this is
where he would meet the future
co-founders of deep mind in 2010 so what
is the goal of deepmind technologies
according to their website their goal is
to solve intelligence they are trying to
achieve this by combining the best
techniques from machine learning and
systems neuroscience to build powerful
general-purpose learning algorithms or
in other words they want to formalize
intelligence find out what it is and how
it works
the endgame is not just to implement
this into machines but also understand
the human brain demos explains further
quote attempting to distill intelligence
into an algorithmic construct may prove
to be the best path to understanding
some of the enduring mysteries of our
minds end quote
the key here is that this machine is
general-purpose this is very important
but more on this later okay so how does
this all work the AI from deep mind uses
a technique called deep reinforcement
learning which makes it very different
from other AIS such as IBM's Watson or
the primitives theory or Google now the
AIS just mentioned were only developed
for a predefined purpose and only
function within their scope deep mind
claims that their system is not
pre-programmed and it learns from
experience using only raw pixels as data
input so the way we start off training
alphago is by showing it a hundred
thousand games that strong amateurs are
played that we've downloaded from the
internet
and we first initially get alphago to
mimic the human player but of course
ultimately we would like
alphago to be stronger than human
amateurs and compete with the top
professionals so the way we do that is
after we take that first version that's
learn to mimic human play we then allow
it to play itself 30 million times on
our servers and using reinforcement
learning it the system learns to improve
itself incrementally through avoiding
its errors and increasing and improving
its win rate against older versions of
itself and after all these games then
you end up with a new version that can
beat the old version the original
version around 1897 technically the
reinforcement that deepmind uses is
model free meaning that it doesn't need
a structure or set of rules to learn
according to MIT s take on the Google
algorithm the neural network in theory
should be able to access an external
memory in a manner that mimics the
short-term memory of the human brain in
a way it almost seems like our brains
design might be the most efficient way
for the creation of local intelligence
who would have guessed
so that's all good what about this
general-purpose term what does that
actually mean well because the machine
learns from bore experience and data it
can perform well across a wide variety
of tasks straight out of the box okay so
that's enough talk let's watch the
system in action learning how to play
break out and remember the machine
didn't have any foreknowledge as to what
task it was going to complete it had to
figure out how to do everything only
from its own experience is the machine
before training so this is literally the
first time the machine has ever seen
this data stream and it's controlling
the green rocket here and it's and you
can see it's losing its three lives
immediately so it's basically terrible
at the game as you would expect
now after training this is like
overnight we leave it playing the game
overnight on a normal computer computer
so for about eight hours you come back
in the morning and now it's superhuman
level so now the machine can play space
invaders better than any human can it
smuggled the world the game world so
while it knows where the space foam
Raiders will be ahead of time so as the
space invaders speed up when you get
less of them on the screen it does as
far as
short is a kind of predictive shot of
where the final Space Invader will be in
a few seconds but the cool thing is
after understanding how to play a few
games it will be able to transfer this
knowledge and understanding across more
games at the moment deep mind is
currently playing games from the 1970s
and 80s but work is currently being done
on more complex 3d games such as doom
which appeared in the early 90s
so what could general-purpose AI be
useful we'd love to use these types of
algorithms for things like healthcare
and science and improve the speed of
breakthroughs in those areas by helping
human experts achieve more in a number
of interviews Denis has talked about
applications and healthcare smartphone
assistance and robotics as possible
applications for general AI some other
applications of such AI include online
customer service
computer vision finance general computer
science and news publishing and writing
general purpose AI actually could be
huge it can be thought of as another
emerging science much like Newtonian
physics laid the groundwork for
technology such as rockets a science
founded in general purpose digital
neural networks that use reinforcement
learning could lay the groundwork for
unimaginable things in the near future
ok so almost at the end of the video but
there's one pressing question should we
be worried in the thousands of years of
meaningful civilization our modern
existence right now is an anomaly we've
overcome the limits of nature with
technology that helps us facilitate such
a lifestyle but artificial intelligence
is different the reason being AI is the
first thing humans have created that
tends to function in a way that we can't
predict so should we worry my belief is
that the fear of the unknown is mostly
what drives the hysteria that arises
from AI anxiety there's not enough time
in this video to go through all the
theories of how things could turn out
but it's an interesting topic within
itself the website wait but why has a
fairly interesting and comprehensive
look at AI we don't have time to explore
it all but the article does raise an
interesting point though it's about how
humans have an inner bill
to perceive exponential change for a
long time people aren't going to take AI
seriously and it would seem like
progress is very slow but then suddenly
it could overtake our wildest
expectations one of the methods that AI
could use to achieve this outcome is by
giving itself an ability for self
improvement thus following the law of
accelerating returns Stephen Hawking and
Elon Musk have both shown their
reservations towards AI but others like
Paul Ellen co-founder of Microsoft have
different views if you can forget about
the movie Terminator for a second there
is a possibility that AI could be man's
greatest aide fixing fundamental
problems on our planet and allowing us
to have technology and infrastructure
that could have otherwise taken us
centuries if we try to figure it out
ourselves but on the other hand there is
a possibility that AI could be malicious
and would outwit us but at this stage we
really just don't know yet and again
this is a story for another day so at
the moment I'm not worried but
cautiously optimistic as for deep mind
one of their conditions after Google's
acquisition was that they establish an
AI Ethics Board and I think most of us
would agree that that's a prudent
decision all in all we may be at a
historic point a critical point in
artificial intelligence the future could
see deep neural Learning and general
purpose AI in our smartphones and
computers some say that we might even
have to start thinking of a whole new
economy reason being AI could take over
a lot of information intensive
specialized jobs leaving only jobs that
are creative or emotional in nature
something that a I might never achieve I
honestly can't say where all of this
will lead with any certainty but then
again I don't think anyone can if you
take a look at the macro picture in all
of this after many decades of trying to
build smarter computers and algorithms
it turns out that the best blueprint was
in our heads the whole time the human
brain so naturally our minds are capable
of so much it just depends on how we use
it
so that's the end of the video thanks
for watching guys don't forget to give
this video a thumbs up if you liked it
leave a comment and subscribe if you're
new you might want to do that if you
want to see some more cool stuff just
hang around for the next 10 seconds and
follow the prompts in your screen cheers
guys thanks for watching and I'll see
you again soon for the next video have a
good one